alrighty today we are going to be
reviewing dune part one first this video
is brought to you by ring
so let's start off with the fact that
this may be the best looking science
fiction movie ever so denis villeneuve
who's the director he makes a great
looking product right blade runner 2049
is a fantastic looking movie and so his
arrival and this movie is just
spectacular looking like from beginning
to end every shot is a piece of art it
was sort of described by a lot of folks
as david lean style shots of the desert
that's correct i mean it does look like
lawrence of arabia which makes sense
because the plot is kind of like
lawrence of arabia but the color scheme
is wonderful every shot is beautifully
constructed the special effects are
great you see every dollar on the screen
there are some movies where they cost a
bajillion dollars you're like really the
sci-fi elements here look crappy the
computer generation looks awful here
everything just looks first-rate looks
great
and so just on a pure aesthetic level
it's a beautiful movie to watch the
acting is excellent across the board the
score is overwrought i like hans zimmer
but hans zimmer basically just takes the
blade runner 2049 square and plops it
right in the center with some very high
pitched singing and some throat singing
from like vikings or something i think
that the score is overdone because the
movie is so weighty that you don't
actually need to make the movie
weightier by use of the score it's a
very dark movie just visually it's dark
but it is also the story is very dark so
you don't need the music to do that much
work and it's it's a little bit
obtrusive not a bad score it's just not
my favorite han zimmer score but bottom
line is that just as a piece of film
making it's
triumphant spoilers abound essentially
the plot of the movie goes like this you
have house of tradies which is led by
oscar isaac his son is timothy chalamet
and his concubine who he never married
is rebecca ferguson right there on one
side on the other side you have house
harkening which is kind of a stand-in
for the soviets kind of so these two
families are fighting over the planet
iraqis the harkinan had dominance over
the planet of arrakis for some 80 years
and now that planet has been taken away
from them and handed to house of
treaties by the emperor so you never
meet the empire you know you don't know
who the emperor is what you do know is
that he is afraid of house of trade he's
gaining support and then presumably
taking power so what he does he sort of
puts them on arrakis in order to
generate what is the most valuable
commodity in the universe which is
called spice okay now spice is
essentially the oil of the universe
right it is this property that allows
people to fly for interstellar periods
of time and it's also a hallucinogen
and it's holy to the people who live
on arrakis who are known as the fremen
the idea here is that house harkin is
going to attack the empire is going to
quietly support house harkenin and the
attributes are going to go down so
there's a lot of ins and outs there you
meet a lot of different characters you
meet the the fremen leaders one of them
is played by javier bardem who's
actually pretty terrific uh you have
jason mamoa who plays sort of the
military go-between who knows the fremen
and is able to act as a broker between
the fremen and house atreides the
character's name is duncan idaho which
is again very sci-fi zendaya is in it
but doesn't say anything she's just in a
lot of sort of cutaway prophecy shots
meanwhile oscar isaac is trying to train
his son to take over for him in case of
his death and his son of course is sort
of hesitant he has these visions of what
the future is going to be like where
he's the leader of this giant jihad like
this is this huge rebellion against the
empire and he's seen as a holy figure
throughout the entire film by the way
he's being seen as a potential holy
figure by the freman because there have
been all these prophecies about an
outsider who's going to come to the
planet and is going to lead just such a
rebellion he has certain powers because
his mom is essentially a witch she
belongs to an order called benny jesuit
and she's taught her son a few of the
tricks of the benny jesuit so he can use
essentially what is the old jedi mind
trick on people he can speak to them and
make them do what he wants to do by
setting his voice to a certain timber he
kind of fulfills the basic notion of
what this messianic figure on the planet
is supposed to be oscar isaac's plan is
that he's going to get to the planet and
he's going to make common cause with the
fremen they're going to allow him to
mine the spice that they need and he's
going to basically leave them alone and
there's a pretty intense scene where
there is a sand trawler that is picking
up the spice and mining the spice and
it's attacked by one of the sand worms
and it's a pretty amazing scene it's an
amazing looking scene house harkin ends
up attacking iraq is the giant pretty
spectacular looking battle ensues the
house of atreides goes down oscar isaac
is captured he is killed but not before
he poisons the head of house harkonnen
with poison that is hidden in his tooth
and meanwhile timothy chalamet escapes
to the desert with his mom and he has
this vision in the desert and he is very
upset about this because his mom made
him a freak and he doesn't really want
to take up this mantle but he realizes
that they have to survive and so they
wander out into the desert and they are
trying to find the fremen
the biggest issue with the movie is that
it ends kind of randomly now we knew
because it was called dune part one that
there will be a part two and so some
people are saying well you know so what
it cut off in the middle like why is
that a big deal the answer is that it's
not a big deal that it cut off in the
middle the problem is that it cut off in
the middle of a story beat which is a
very weird place to actually cut off the
movie so it feels strangely 15 minutes
too long and two and a half hours too
short if you're gonna do the whole story
it's got to be probably five or six
hours it made a great mini series if
you're going to cut off the movie in the
middle then really they should have cut
off the movie maybe 20 minutes sooner he
starts to meet with the fremen they find
the fremen they have this interaction
where he has to beat one of the feminine
in a knife fight and then the movie ends
after he meets zendaya the weird part
about that is that should be the
beginning of the second movie right my
problem is not that there's a break in
the movie there's a break in fellowship
of the ring also the difference is that
fellowship of the ring concludes at one
point and right before they start the
next point that's when the movie stops
right it stops after boromir is killed
and they're about to enter into the
jagged wasteland and they're about to
meet gollum right what would've been
weird in fellowship is if frodo and sam
had left the riverbank gone up and met
gollum and then as soon as they meet
gollum that's when you stop the movie
that would be strange right that's what
dune does it would have been better to
me if they're in the desert he gets out
they're searching for the fremen but
things are as desperate as they can be
because his dad is dead and because
harkening is taking over the planet and
that's sort of where things break
instead they break i think in the wrong
place my problem isn't the break my
problem is that the break is in the
wrong place already we'll get some more
on dune in just one second first let me
remind you i keep my home protected with
ring i care a lot about home safety
because frankly a lot of people know who
i am i want to make sure that my family
is safe make sure that my home is safe
particularly when i'm out of town with
my ring alarm security system i'm much
more at ease when i'm on the road or
away from home my ring alarm equals
peace of mind ring alarm is a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app it's the perfect way to
start that ring experience keep an eye
on every corner of your house with
indoor and outdoor cams see what's
happening directly from your phone and
it is super easy to install it yourself
i am no tech wiz but even i could
install the ring alarm myself protect
your home anytime from anywhere with
ring alarm go to ring.com for a special
offer on a ring alarm security kit today
you can build a system that is right for
your home have it up and running in just
minutes that's ring.comring.com
not only does it allow me to keep tabs
on what's going on in my house when i'm
not at my house also when i'm at my
house and i just lose track of one of
the kids i pop up that ring app and i
can find exactly where they are that is
super useful ring.com again
ben as for the feel of the film it
really does mirror the books the book is
cold sci-fi there's some sci-fi books
that are that are very warm and and you
really feel a lot for the characters
fahrenheit 451 is one that comes to mind
this is not a book like that it's very
long it's kind of technical it's
notoriously hard to adapt because it's
so sprawling and it covers so much
ground and it covers so much time but
you know because the move is kind of a
cold director it works it does work
really really well so i will say that
every time the shy hallude which is this
giant sand worm approaches the graphics
are just astonishingly good when it
travels through the dunes it's super
cool because it's traveling through the
dunes in the way that a missile would
travel through waves that's what it
looks like it's really neat looking
i think the movie is actually great i
think it's gonna be hard to
adjudicate whether the movie is is great
actually until you get a second part
because you don't know what the
conclusion of the movie looks like it
could be a complete disaster area in
which case the first half is great and
the second half sucks but if this
completes in the way that the first half
is done i think it's going to be one of
the great sci-fi epics of all time i
will say i feel pretty secure in his
hands like as a director when you're a
moviegoer there are certain directors
where you just feel good walking into
the theater because you know you're
going to get something that is at least
going to be really fascinating and
valmov is one of those directors right
to me nolan is the key director who's
like that but villeneuve is clearly like
that too and he's really made his mark
here so i'm really excited frankly to
see the second movie i will say that i
think it was such a bad release strategy
to release it simultaneously on hbo max
this is a big kind of industry insider
thing right now is whether you should
have simultaneous release of these films
on a streaming platform as well as in
the theaters this is not a movie you
should be watching on your tiny little
cell phone you should really be seeing
this on an imax theater because the
visuals are just spectacular so the
movie made 40 million domestic 220
worldwide this movie certainly would
have opened at 89 million bucks if this
were not available on streaming this
would have been a massive opening i
think hollywood is going to pretty
quickly move away from the simultaneous
streaming release with the theaters i
think the theaters are going to come
back and come back in a pretty strong
way if they don't it's going to be hard
to get movies like this made to my
recommendation go check this out in a
theater it's a huge movie it looks
beautiful it's definitely worth the
watch or maybe wait until part two comes
out and then watch them back to back
into theater which is definitely
something that i would do alrighty if
you enjoyed our review make sure to
smash that like button make sure to
subscribe as well leave us a comment in
the comments section below let us know
what other material you'd like me to
review
[Music]